jQuery is a very popular lightweight
javascript library the purpose of jQuery
is to make it much easier to use
JavaScript on websites jQuery simplifies
a lot of the complicated things from
JavaScript like Ajax calls and Dom
manipulation to use it you can either
download it and host it yourself or you
can just link to a CDN a lot of people
just use a CDN so to do that you just go
into your HTML file and put this line so
right within the head tag you can see we
have the head tag here and inside that
you're gonna put this line script and
its source equals and then you just link
to the jQuery here that jQuery CDN if
you can't remember what that is you can
just go to google and type in jQuery CDN
and you can also download it from jQuery
comm and if you were creating something
on code bin like I am right now there is
an even easier way to add jQuery you
just go to settings and then on the
JavaScript tab quick add you go down to
jQuery and they just click Save and
close and then you don't even have to
put the script here it for you so down
the JavaScript code here I'm going to
show you the basic syntax of jQuery
you're always going to start with the
dollar sign and then in parentheses
you're gonna put a selector now this
selector can be any CSS selector and
then you're gonna put dot and then
you're gonna put the action so whatever
action you're going to have jQuery
perform with that CSS selector so I'm
gonna get rid of this I'm just about to
copy and paste some code that has three
jQuery commands and what we're going to
talk about those okay so here are three
jQuery commands so this first jQuery
command is is kind of special you're
usually gonna want to put your entire
code in a document dot ready event so
document that ready just means when the
document is ready or when the document
is completely loaded then you're going
to run the rest of your code if you
don't put your code and adapter with
that ready event your code may try to
access an element from the HTML that has
not
yet loaded so this just selects the
document and when it's ready it runs
this code so now let's look at the code
inside the document dot ready event
again we start with the dollar sign and
then we the CSS selector button is just
going to select the the button tag right
here and then we're gonna add a click
action or a click event so this is going
to be the action click and when the
button is clicked we're going to run the
command that's inside that so inside we
have another jQuery command you know
it's jQuery that starts with a dollar
sign and then we're gonna select the P
tags and we're going to hide them so
there's two P tags here you'll see these
two right here so if I click the belt
button the P tags are hidden I'm just
gonna reset that and we're gonna change
the code a little bit so I'm just going
to change this one right here I'm going
to change this to cereal with the hash
sign or the pound sign right before this
that's just the CSS selector for ID so
you can see up here ID of cereal so now
it's gonna select this whole thing right
here so if we run that and then we click
the button it just hit the paragraph
element with the ID of cereal and you
can see these two lines one of them is a
Pez appear graph tag one of them as a
div tag but they both have the same
class of unicycle so if we just use the
CSS dot unicycle that's how you would
show a class the dot if I click the
button it hides everything that it's the
unicycle and I'll show you one more way
you can mix this up here we've been
selecting the button to add the click
event but we can also make this h3 so we
can we can really add the click event to
anything and now we're going to hide the
button so let's see what happens there
when I click the button now nothing
happens but if they click the heading
the button disappears ok that's just a
quick introduction to jQuery I'm gonna
be going over more information about
jQuery and future
videos thanks for watching my name is
beau Carnes don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good